urteil zur datenabfrage das
bundesverfassungsgericht begrenzt den
zugriff der ermittler auf private handy
und internetdaten eu sondergipfel zu
corona helfen die regierungschefs ringen
um viele milliarden euro ausgang offen
konsequenzen nach droh-mails nach den
massiven beleidigungen gegen prominente
frauen kündigt essens polizeichef eine
neue strategie an
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und willkommen
zu unserem nachrichtenüberblick am
freitag mit dabei für den sport norbert
lehmann einen schönen antwort von mir
und wir beginnen mit einer spannenden
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts das heute den
schutz privater daten gestärkt hat
danach dürfen ermittler künftig nur noch
dann persönliche daten abfragen wenn der
konkrete verdacht auf eine straftat
besteht in dem fall dürfen die
informationen zur gefahrenabwehr genutzt
werden etwa um terroranschläge zu
verhindern oder um verbrechen
aufzuklären
dafür dürfen die behörden auf sogenannte
bestandsdaten zu greifen das sind name
private anschrift und handynummer das
geburtsdatum oder auch die ip-adresse
sogar die kontonummer gehört dazu
die hürde an diese daten zu kommen soll
nun höher werden
christoph schneider berichtet für ihn
ist es ein deutlicher juristischer
erfolg patrick breyer
seit jahren kämpft die eu abgeordnete
der piratenpartei gegen massenhafte
datenüberwachung seine jetzt
erfolgreiche beschwerde vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht wurde von mehr
als 6000 menschen unterstützt
die regierung wollte er auf unsere daten
sogar zugriff nehmen um
ordnungswidrigkeiten also zum beispiel
strafzettel zu verfolgen
da wurde kein konkreter verdacht einer
straftat voraus gesetzt und das ist viel
zu weit geht und behindert politische
aktivitäten behindert auch die
pressefreiheit nicht nur für den kläger
ist der gesetzgeber damit zu weit
gegangen
auch das bundesverfassungsgericht sich
diese staatlichen zugriffsmöglichkeiten
auf persönliche daten von handy und
internet nutzern ohne genehmigung als zu
weitgehend an nachrichtendienste bka und
polizei nutzen die auskünfte um
terroranschläge zu verhindern oder um
verbrechen aufzuklären
dazu dürfen sie zb bei
telefongesellschaften und providern die
festen bestandsdaten abfragen
das geht aber nur wenn eine konkrete
gefahr oder ein anfangsverdacht zur
strafverfolgung vorliegt sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt
die ermittler sehen probleme die hürden
für uns um eben auf die bestandsdaten
zurück zu treffen sind noch einmal
konkretisiert sind noch mal erhöht
worden und das wird für unsere
ermittlungstätigkeiten nochmal an
erschweren es sein
der ball ist aus karlsruhe wieder nach
berlin zurück gespielt worden wo nun
wieder der gesetzgeber zum handeln
aufgefordert ist ja und damit ist der
gesetzgeber ja nun schon zum zweiten mal
vom bundesverfassungsgericht gerüffelt
worden
christian decker von recht und justiz
ist bei uns im studio
es ist ja für den staat auch eine
schwierige gratwanderung zwischen
einerseits zwischen dem recht auf
informationelle selbstbestimmung also
den datenschutz und andererseits eben
einer effektiven strafverfolgung bei der
strafverfolgung von zum beispiel bereits
im bereich terrorismus sind die
sicherheitsbehörden wie das bka eben auf
solche daten in ihrer täglichen arbeit
angewiesen denn in der heutigen zeit
findet unsere kommunikation ja
hauptsächlich über telefon und internet
statt und da spielt das eine wichtige
rolle für die öffentliche sicherheit
die zahl oder die menge dieser abfragen
das ist aber schon enorm also im
vergangenen jahr wurde zum beispiel von
staatlichen stellen mehr als 16
millionen mal abgefragt wie meine
telefonnummer gehört und der staat
der gesetzgeber muss ja immer eine
balance finden zwischen einerseits dem
öffentlichen der öffentlichen sicherheit
und andererseits aber natürlich den
grundrechten und den freiheiten der
bürgerinnen und bürger und das ist in
diesem fall ganz eindeutig nicht
gelungen
der gesetzgeber muss jetzt eine
neuregelung finden und zwar da muss er
sich sehr beeilen denn er hat damit zeit
nur bis ende 2021 und da im kommenden
jahr ja bundestagswahl ist wird die zeit
noch knapp vielen dank dass sie uns das
erklärt haben danke christian decker es
ist das erste mal seit corona dass die
eu staats und regierungschefs wieder
persönlich beraten
beim sondergipfel in brüssel geht es um
den künftigen haushalt der eu
vor allem aber um das ziel europas
wirtschaft zu retten
die so sehr leidet unter den folgen der
korona krise dafür sollen sie
150 milliarden euro bereitgestellt
werden
doch wer kriegt wie viel zu welchen
bedingungen und muss wann was
zurückzahlen
darüber wird heftig gestritten aus
brüssel berichtet lück walpert seit
sieben stunden suchen sie nach dem
gemeinsamen nenner
es geht sowohl um details als auch ums
grundsätzliche sollen die
schuldenfinanzierten neuen milliarden
zum wiederaufbau der wirtschaft als
kredite fließen oder als beihilfen die
niederlande dänemark schweden und
österreich wollen verbindliche zusagen
dass in den empfängerländern erst einmal
arbeitsmarkt und
sozialversicherungssysteme modernisiert
werden er die milliarden fließen nicht
in zukunftsinvestitionen verwendet wird
wenn es nicht auch hand in hand geht mit
notwendigen reformen in staaten die
schlicht und ergreifend in ihren
systemen kaputt sind oder zumindest
große probleme haben dann wird all das
verputzen statt bevormundung fordern die
von der korona krise besonders
betroffenen staaten spanien und italien
mehr solidarität
berlin - für italien ist die rote linie
dass die eu eine effiziente und
angemessene antwort auf die enorme
herausforderung der krise findet
angenähert hat man sich noch nicht
entsprechend vorsichtig äußerte sich
bundeskanzlerin merkel zu
erfolgsaussichten
aber ich muss sagen dass die
unterschiede doch noch sehr sehr groß
sind und ich deshalb noch nicht
voraussagen kann ob wir bei diesem mal
schon zu einem ergebnis kommen
auch bei der diskussion über den
künftigen eu haushalt sind die
spannungen nicht ausgeräumt dass
zahlungen aus brüssel an die einhaltung
rechtsstaatlicher standards geknüpft
werden sollen lehnt ungarns
regierungschef orban strikt ab zur
stunde hat sich die runde erst einmal
aufgelöst um 20 uhr wird beim abendessen
weiter diskutiert eine schwierige
gemengelage anne gellinek in brüssel die
bundeskanzlerin hat ja schon selbst die
erwartungen gedämpft wird sie denn
überhaupt derart verschiedene interessen
miteinander versöhnen können also nach
der ersten acht stunden langen
plenarsitzung der staats und
regierungschefs sieht es danach noch
nicht aus jeder staats und
regierungschefs noch einmal sagen in der
ganz großen runde was ihm oder ihr an
im haushaltsplan das feld und so hat man
versucht die probleme einzukreisen
eine einigung gibt es natürlich nur wenn
alle seiten sich bewegen und jeder vom
jeweiligen baum herunter klettert die
sparsamen die selbsternannten sparsamen
nordeuropäer müssten also akzeptieren
dass aus dem corona hilfstopf eben nicht
nur kredite sondern auch zuschüsse
fließen und die südeuropäischen
empfängerländer müssten die kröte
schlucken dass diese gelder eben an
strengere kontrollmechanismen
kontrollmechanismen gebunden wären
insgesamt würde das niveau sowohl des
corona hilft hilfsjobs als auch des
eu-haushaltes singen sinken um den
nordeuropäern entgegen zu kommen aber so
weit sind wir noch nicht noch reden die
staats und regierungschefs gleich beim
abendessen weiter möglicherweise gibt es
heute nacht einen neuen
kompromissvorschlag zum haushalt von
schall michelle darüber würden die
staats und regierungschefs am morgen
weiter fahren denn eine einigung scheint
heute abend ausgeschlossen und morgen
ist ein neuer tag und dann reden wir
wieder über den gipfel vielen dank an
der gellinek nach brüssel
in der affäre um anonyme mails mit
todesdrohungen an politikerinnen der
linken journalistinnen und eine
kabarettistin geht hessens innenminister
bouffier vorwärtsverteidigung
sein ziel den ruf der eigenen
polizeibehörden wieder herzustellen eine
schwierige aufgabe weil persönliche
informationen der mail opfer aus polizei
computern abgerufen worden waren
stefan schlosser fasst zusammen mit nsu
2.0 und heil hitler unterschriebene e
mails erreichen immer mehr adressaten
sie enthalten wüste beleidigungen und
todesdrohungen möglicherweise stammt der
absender aus den reihen der polizei
diesen vorwurf muss sich nun die gesamte
polizei vereint entgegenstellen und
durch ihr tägliches handeln belegen dass
sie zu recht großes vertrauen in der
bevölkerung genießt
in mindestens drei fällen wurden
persönliche daten unerlaubt von
hessischen polizei rechnen abgefragt der
zugriff soll in zukunft genau
überprüfbar sein kündigte heute der neue
polizeipräsident an
außerdem soll die ermittlungsarbeit
weiter gestärkt die betreuung
betroffener ausgebaut werden
bisher sei zu wenig passiert kritisiert
die opposition
da sind 60 beamte angeblich damit
beschäftigt den vorfall aufzuklären und
sie haben bisher nichts heraus gefunden
dass spricht gute ermittlungsarbeit
hohen wir können nur hoffen dass da
jetzt neue zeit anbricht in dem sinne
dass sie jetzt ernsthaft mal ermitteln
auffallend ist dass vor allem frauen zu
den adressaten gehören frauen die eine
stimme haben sie passen nicht ins
weltbild von rechtsextremisten frauen
haben zu dienen frauen haben mütter zu
sein aber sie haben nicht selbstbewusste
eigenständige persönlichkeiten zu sein
sie sind wirklich auf rang sie sind
provokationen sie gehören nicht in diese
gesellschaft wie sie von den
rechtsextremisten gedacht wird solange
es keine konkreten ergebnisse gibt steht
die hessische polizei weiter unter
beobachtung und mit ihr auch der
innenminister im schwarzwald hat die
polizei den bewaffneten 31 jährigen
gefasst der sich tagelang versteckt
hielt er hatte am sonntag vier beamte in
einem waldstück bedroht und ihnen ihre
dienstwaffen abgenommen seitdem fahndet
die polizei mit spezialeinheiten
hundestaffeln und hubschraubern nach dem
mann
er soll vorbestraft und wohnungslos
seien nach syrien wo der präsident des
geschundenen landes heute genau seit 20
jahren regiert am 17 juli 2000 übernimmt
baschir al assad die macht von seinem
verstorbenen vater diktator hafeez kurz
gilt es hat auch im ausland als
hoffnungsträger der das land öffnen
könnte doch spätestens seit den
aufständen des arabischen frühlings geht
sein regime äußerst brutal gegen
politische gegner vor neun jahre dauert
jetzt der bürgerkrieg katrin eigendorf
aus idlib der letzten rebellenhochburg
idlib ist die letzte region die nicht
unter kontrolle des regimes in damaskus
steht und von aufständischen
islamistischen rebellen gehalten wird
mehr als drei millionen syrer die hälfte
von ihnen kinder drängen sich hier die
meisten sind vor den regierungstruppen
geflohen
es fehlt an allem zugänge zu hilfe wird
von den machthabern in damaskus immer
weiter beschränkt
wir haben nichts wir warten auf den
eimer mit lebensmitteln den wir jeden
monat bekommen damit wir zu essen haben
dass die korona pandemie diese lager
erreichen könnte ein schreckensszenario
seit dieser woche ist es realität
mitarbeiter der syrischen
zivilschutzorganisation weiß helme die
sonst bombenopfer bergen kämpfen nun
gegen das virus
wir haben eine kampagne für achtsamkeit
gestartet wir versuchen alles um zu
verhindern dass sich das virus weiter
verbreitet
ein arzt hatte sich in der türkei
infiziert und das virus eingeschleppt
inzwischen gibt es zwölf infizierte und
die frage wie soll unter solchen
umständen eine rasante vermehrung
vermieden werden
das wasser reicht gerade zum trinken
abstand halten und regelmäßig hände
waschen unmöglich provisorische
gesundheitsstationen sollen helfen denn
viele krankenhäuser in idlib wurden
durch russische luftangriffe zerstört
keine guten aussichten für eine von
rebellen kontrollierte region die als
bastion des schutzes vor den
vorrückenden truppen des assad-regimes
gilt
jeder tag wird zum traurigen rekord bei
den täglichen neuinfektionen mit corona
liegen die usa einsam an der spitze mehr
als 77.000 sind es inzwischen tendenz
steigend der kampf gegen das virus wird
auch zum graben kampf um die massen
pflicht politiker der demokraten und
republikaner zehn wegen der masken vor
gericht britta jäger aus den usa
überfüllte krankenhäuser überlastete
medizin
es sind verheerende bilder aus den
corona hotspots im süden der usa george
zählte allein gestern gut 3400
neuinfektionen an dem anstieg hier seien
aber nicht die früheren lockerungen
sondern die proteste gegen rassismus
schuld meint der republikanische
gouverneur und stemmt sich gegen eine
masken pflicht viele gut informierte und
besorgte bürger wollen eine masken
pflicht und obwohl wir alle zustimmen
dass das tragen von masken effektiv ist
bin ich sicher dass die bürger hier
keine pflicht brauchen um das richtige
zu tun
der gouverneur recht klage ein gegen
atlanta die hauptstadt hatte neben
weiteren bezirken einem masten pflicht
verordnet für die demokratische
bürgermeisterin nach einem positiven
corona test zur zeit in quarantäne ist
klar
mit der klage will der republikaner nur
donald trump gefallen
ich habe angemerkt dass donald trump
unsere massen pflicht verletzt hat als
er auf unserem flughafen gelandet war
und keine maske getragen hatte
deshalb klagt der gouverneur jetzt und
es ist sehr deutlich dass er seine
politik über die menschen stellt
unterdessen beschäftigt sich der
präsident damit gemeinsam mit seiner
tochter lebensmittel eines konzerns zu
bewerben dessen chef trump in höchsten
tönen gelobt hatte es kam zum boykott
aufrufen
die schmutzkampagne der radikalen linken
sei nach hinten losgegangen twitter
trump die menschen würden wie verrückt
goya produkte kaufen ein klarer
amtsmissbrauch meinen ethik experten und
ein affront gegen all jene die glauben
dass amerika zurzeit wichtigere kämpfe
auszutragen hat jetzt zur aktuellen
krone lage in deutschland da steigt die
zahl der neuinfizierten wieder leicht an
bleibt aber insgesamt
auf niedrigem niveau im schnitt der
vergangenen woche haben sich täglich 350
menschen neu mit dem virus angesteckt
davor pendelte die zahl um 3 100 die
korona soforthilfen sollten wie es der
name sagt schnell und unbürokratisch
helfen
das hat auch betrüger angelockt und so
gibt es inzwischen mehr als 5000
vorwürfe wegen subventionsbetrugs der
geldwäsche und der fälschung von daten
in berlin heute ein erstes urteil
dort soll ein unternehmer mit erfundenen
angaben rund 22.000 euro abkassiert
haben rom einlässt cover ein jahr sieben
monate auf bewährung wegen
subventionsbetrugs berlins erstes urteil
zu den corona soforthilfen rund 21.500
euro erhielt der angeklagte für firmen
die teils gar nicht existierten nicht
der einzige fall derzeit für berlins
staatsanwaltschaft
stand anfang juli hatten wir über 700
ermittlungsverfahren bei der
staatsanwaltschaft anhängig weitere
mehrere hundert verfahren die noch bei
der polizei sind täglich steigt die zahl
an berlins aus zahlungsprozess in der
kritik zu wenig kontrolle fahrlässiges
handeln lauteten vorwürfe zuständig war
die investitionsbank online-konten
anträge gestellt werden die auszahlung
sollte notleidende schnell erreichen
tiefen prüfungen größtenteils
nachgelagert erfolgen für den
steuerzahlerbund aus heutiger
perspektive problematisch wir hätten uns
ein intensiveres prüfverfahren gewünscht
teilweise war der antrag sozusagen
abgegeben und einen tag später war schon
das geld das ist zwar schön für den
betroffenen aber alles muss seine recht
und ordnung haben die investitionsbank
sieht sich zu unrecht in der kritik
soforthilfe wie politisch gewollt wäre
anders kaum möglich gewesen eine
individuelle tiefen prüfung jedes
einzelnen falls hätte im falle der ibb
bedeutet das schiff für etwa vier monate
lang 750 mitarbeiter gebraucht hätten
die hätten wir weder technisch noch
organisatorische einbinden können die
juristische aufarbeitung der korona
soforthilfen mit dem urteil durfte sie
noch lange nicht zu ende sein
tja und nun tritt hier norbert und zum
zweiten teil des tenniscamps
einladungsturniers in berlin
da wurde ja zunächst im steffi graf
stadion auf rasen gespielt jetzt ist man
in einen hangar des ehemaligen
flughafens tempelhof umgezogen auf den
hartplatz und da gab es heute ein
spannendes deutsches viertelfinale
zwischen jan lennard struff und ex profi
tommy haas
der frust von jan lennard struff war
verständlich bei diesem
außergewöhnlichen spiel gegen sein
früheres idol vor nicht alltäglicher
kulisse am berliner flughafen tempelhof
der 42-jährige tommy haas auch drei
jahre nach dem karriereende noch
überraschend fit gewinnt den ersten satz
im tie break gegen den zwölf jahre
jüngeren stoff auch der zweite satz wird
erst im tie-break entschieden und wieder
ist es haas der mit nervenstärke und
souveränem ersten aufschlag überzeugt
und das match überraschend für sich
entscheidet
das ist weltklasse tennis ich kann das
auch nicht jeden tag mehr spielen das
ist keiner physik kann ja keine frage
und ich spüre auch mein körper die
erholungszeit ist kurz im halbfinale
morgen wartet dann die nummer drei der
welt der österreicher dominic thiem der
deutsche präsident des internationalen
olympischen komitees thomas bach will
für eine weitere amtszeit kandidieren
das gab er heute auf der ioc
generalversammlung bekannt
dort wurden auch die austragungsorte und
der zeitplan für die auf 2.021
verschobenen olympischen sommerspiele in
tokio bestätigt andere schule beendet
ganz überraschend seine fußballkarriere
mit 29 jahren 2014 steht der fußball
geschichte mit seinem präzisen pass auf
den torschützen mario götze beim
deutschen 1 0-sieg gegen argentinien im
wm finale in brasilien
der weltmeister spielte später für
borussia dortmund und wurde zuletzt an
spartak moskau ausgeliehen
am mittwoch hatten sich der bvb und
schule einvernehmlich getrennt vom
früheren weltmeister zum neuen
spanischen meister gestern abend holte
real madrid vorzeitig den titel
durch den 2 1 heimsieg am vorletzten
spieltag gegen villarreal karim benzema
der doppeltorschütze
die 34 meisterschaft für real die zweite
für den deutschen nationalspieler toni
kroos in madrid ebenso wie für zinedine
zidan dem gefeierten real-trainer gute
akrobatische leistung ohne abstand muss
man sagen danke und zum schluss noch der
britische hält in dieser krisenzeit
tumor weltkriegsveteran 100 jahre alt
wurde heute von der queen zum ritter
geschlagen mit seinem corona spendenlauf
marathon am rollator in seinem garten
sammelte er unglaubliche 3 36 millionen
euro ein
für das unterfinanzierte britische
gesundheitssystem so wurde er
weltberühmt und ein großes vorbild
captain turmuhr ein echter ritter
wer nur auf den kniefall vor der queen
hat er verzichtet und mit britischem
humor bemerkt dann käme er nie mehr hoch
morgen wird es deutlich wärmer und oft
sonnig ob es am sonntag so weitergeht
dazu gleich mehr von katja horneffer das
was von uns schön dass sie dabei waren
mehr hat das heute journal mit bettina
schausten gegen 10 uhr und wir sind
morgen wieder für sie der punkt 19 uhr
einen schönen start ins wochenende
wünschen wird
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren zwischen
diesem tief über osteuropa und den tief
bei island bleibt jetzt am wochenende in
mitteleuropa doch wirklich platz für die
sonne
und da sind die nächte zum teil auch
klar da können sie ja mal nach dem comic
mio weiß ausschau halten heute nacht
fällt höchstens an den alpen noch etwas
regen sonst ist es oft klar ab und zu
bildet sich auch mal nebel bei
temperaturen von 14 bis 7 grad
morgen wird ein freundlicher tag sonne
und wolken wechseln sich ab und einzig
im berchtesgadener land kann es noch
etwas regnen und auch im nordwesten sind
einzelne schauer nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen
die temperaturen steigen morgen meist
auf 24 bis 27 grad
nur auf rügen und zwischen dem thüringer
wald und dem alpenrand bleibt es bei 20
bis 22 grad etwas kühler
am sonntag steigen die werden dann auf
23 bis 30 grad und im osten kann es dann
spätestens am nachmittag doch einige
gewitter geben
am montag werden dann von nordwesten
neue regenschauer und gewitter heran
ziehen dass es da eine kleine kaltfront
am dienstag liegen daher die
temperaturen nur noch bei 17 bis 27 grad
der mittwoch wird er meist wieder
freundlich nur am alpenrand drohen
einzelne gewitter schönen abend noch